welcome to season two of the Von cast I
couldn't think of a better way to kick
it off
um and then with my guy Stefan Diggs
three-time pro bowler him
um my first repeat guest on the Von cast
Stefan Diggs appreciate you my boy for
sure
um use that Fashion Week last night we
just played on Monday yesterday was
Tuesday yeah we was moving around last
night I had some moving Parts uh I went
to uh actually I didn't care for women
dinner by Karen group uh you know moving
around just trying to do the right stuff
it's dope man Mr international Man all
across the U.S too man
um Monday Night Football I didn't go it
didn't go as we planned I felt like
you know I was talking to the guys in
the facility today I felt like even if
we of course you want to win but I feel
like even if we did win we would still
feel the same about their game
um it didn't go as planned for us or or
anybody yeah um but the energy in the
stadium was was crazy
um right when you know Aaron Rodgers had
walked out with the flag and everybody
cheered in the smoke and everything
clear like it was it was a crazy
environment man and then all of a sudden
it was it was like flat after he had got
hurt
um what was uh how did you feel about
that I know you play you play offense
you know you're not out there at the
same time as Aaron Rodgers but when that
happened how did you feel it was weird
because like
um
even prior to the game going into you
know you kind of felt the energy you
felt everything going into it it was
exciting and kind of like we of course
like I don't know what it was we kind of
felt like the underdog especially going
in with uh Aaron Rodgers being at the
helm over there and not to be not being
at a disadvantage of anything but it was
going to make the game real interesting
but it was kind of weird also because
last year we played them you know they
were a run first team and when you kind
of added a quarterback and then makes it
kind of seem like okay what they gonna
do they're gonna run first they're going
to throw it around so it kind of like
added another element like this game's
gonna be good I'm saying especially
coming off of last year uh the season
opener you know how exciting that was in
LA so going in you know another big city
um you know it's kind of like a damn
near like a little mini concert it was
it felt I mean the atmosphere was crazy
man and then it was it was flat when it
went down it's a lot of discussion about
grass
artificial turf you know I'm I'm a big
I'm a big proponent of grass like I
don't even I don't even practice I don't
even like to practice on Turf yeah but
this
was the one um situation that I feel
like it didn't matter if it was grass or
turf the way
um
the position that he was in he didn't
hear Leonard Floyd on his waist 250
pounds Aaron Rodgers is already 39. you
know he didn't play he I mean he had
limited reps and then you you put his
ankle in that position I think you know
I love grass I'm a big proponent of
grass I feel like every Stadium should
be grass but I feel like that particular
injury it didn't matter if it was grass
or turf that that would have happened I
mean it's I feel like it's a
double-edged sword like we go into the
game you know it's 100 injury rate game
like everybody knows that distance of a
memory it is while we're playing
um a couple years back I know you can
date it back I feel like I think it was
Minnesota versus uh Green Bay and Aaron
Rodger to shoulder and I think sometime
after that a couple quarterbacks had got
awkwardly hit and they changed the rule
to no landed on the quarterback because
I mean in this in this league now in
this world we live in now you want to
see the offense scoring touchdowns you
want to see exciting things you don't
want to see everybody's favorite
quarterbacks go down you know what I'm
saying when it when he got hurt did get
a little dry out there you know I'm
saying not so much offensively but you
could just know you know the Ebbs and
flows of the game so it was kind of a
little rough to see him being a fan of
football of course you want Aaron
Rodgers out there you you know he's an
opponent and all but I I love I love
competition I was talking about to go
against him but I want to see anybody
out there too man I wanted to see him
out there too um NFL exec Jim Miller had
a uh a quote about you know um the plan
services and you know the stats saying
that it's the same injury rate on grass
and Turf and then the NFL PA
um executive Lloyd Howe had a different
quote this is this just happened like 25
minutes ago yeah saying that you know it
it's it's actually more injuries on
artificial turf
um I just feel like the game was founded
on grass 100 if you look at golf right
if
if the PGA were to live
um tour said hey we're just we're gonna
move we're going to change all the
fields to actual church so we can have
concert concerts on The Fairway I don't
think everybody everybody will be an
uproar with that and I think that's the
same I think that's the same exact thing
that we're doing we're here now you know
our our game is founded on grass you
know it's a football stadium they come
and see football players there yeah they
can have like concerts and stuff there
but they they change it for soccer
players when they come soccer players
when they come over here and play they
never play on Astro attack wow or
artificial grass they always wheel in
natural grass for them to play in and
then they take it off when they leave we
the ones in there I mean we're the ones
in there playing so I feel like the game
was founded on the grass so every
Stadium should be on grass it's gonna be
I think it's going to be a little bit of
a shift too like now uh there's a very
significant injury last night with Aaron
Rodgers as big one of the biggest stars
in sports so stuff like that causes for
a change but it's ironically I'm not
going to speak out of term but I can
vividly remember multiple guys getting
hurt on in MetLife and on that specific
Turf Farm and other guys kind of
commenting throughout the years of a guy
getting hurt on that Turf and like
that's just some bad turf or that
whatever the reason is or whatever the
reason I heard that it was new Turf this
year but Turf in general if you can try
to eradicate or get rid of injuries for
the most part it's already you already
gonna get hurt at one point doing
something if you can kind of get rid of
those small tissues or those injuries
that you know kind of might not take
place if we got a slippery or like a
better surface I think I think I think
Aaron Rodgers would definitely be the
Catalyst to get everything changed for
sure but you had a big night
um you know we was we was rolling early
on when you got your touchdown you you
uh said skiing
yeah the sexy red touchdown
she was she was there too that's why I
said it was you inspired by The Hard
Knocks or just heard me no I heard I
heard they said that after the game and
I was like this uh I mean I knew she was
at the game they had showed her prior to
the game so uh it was a sexy red
touchdown yeah
there we go that song was hard too man
oh yeah I'm not gonna I don't care they
go hard too man um you lined up against
softs
um what makes him special
I think uh being so young and being so
fluid can run
um can make plays on the ball uh he's
definitely on the right team as well you
know I think the head coach does a great
job they got a great front seven eight
guys everybody rotating they're just
giving it everything they got each and
every place so it kind of Works hand in
hand with that uh that d-line and
cornerback position and he's he's a good
player as well uh Jordan Reed I'm not
mistaken uh the four is not a bad player
they got a nice little backhand and then
you see Whitehead had three
interceptions they just they had a good
unit and I still feel like we did enough
to win we just made enough mistakes that
hurt us too much so it just seems like
you know you're one of those you want
back but
as it is in the past yeah it is man the
football guys yeah
yeah September 11th man you just you
just got to talk that one up like they
got another they got another young
player too Gary Wilson yeah um that
touchdown catch was crazy it was crazy
um Trey I mean Trey he was all over him
I mean he's happened to grab it and it
fell in his lap um what do you think
about that catch it was crazy I'm
actually a fan of Guy Wilson like um
coming out of college I think I was one
of his comparisons so I used to watch
him and I was watching him in college uh
and it's ironic enough when he was at
Old State I was saying that he was the
better receiver at Old State and I was
like I like his game he's he can run he
can jump uh he's obviously had a
concentration of having hands of being a
receiver he's kind of putting it on
display in the league I was that was
another piece of me that kind of felt
from when Aaron Rodgers got hurt because
it was going to be interesting to see
his second year jump with an established
quarterback not not that anybody can't
throw him in the ball but you know it's
a little different when you got a Hall
of Fame guy back there uh slinging that
thing around yeah man for sure man and
you know Aaron Rodgers and Aaron Rodgers
and and Gary Wilson they they go
together I announced is Zach and and
Gary Wilson they have to go together too
and you know you and Josh yeah y'all go
together man and we see you on the
sideline encourage and Josh
um you know we uh we struggled yesterday
I mean on Monday we had four turnovers
um but I really love the the imagery of
you encouraging them on the sidelines
like what makes you what what do you say
in those moments and what like inspires
you because it's not just Josh but you
you talk to everybody on the sideline
yeah you know I love football I uh I
take it I take it to heart you know you
give everything you got out there but I
also kind of keep it in the mind frame
of uh
leaders lead everybody differently like
some guys you can like I could come and
push you in the back and be like all
right now Vaughn I need I'm saying like
all positive reinforcement but it comes
from where you where it's coming from
and the delivery of it so for me oh
imagine how hard it is to play
quarterback I can only imagine I can't
put myself in the shoes so
um when things when you have mishaps or
have stuff like that it's just a bunch
of adversity I feel like it's still
football at the end of the day good
things are having bad things won't
happen
um and try not to put too much pressure
on I gotta always got it already got the
weight of you know the whole team on his
back so for me I try to get behind him
in those situations tell them I got you
I'm saying we'll make we'll make it work
we'll figure it out you saw it kind of
started turning the corner towards that
end of the game that last drive you know
I'm saying we start kind of getting on
the same place started clicking so for
me I just feel like that's part of my
job like not only to just you know we
had talked about doing your 111 we're
doing your job my job also is to you
know help them calm down or I'm saying
help keep Gabe in the right mindset keep
Jimbo positive you know I'm saying like
that's that's part of my job as a as a
player on this team not only being the
captain but somebody that just kind of
been around for a little bit so for me I
just take that real serious and I want
us to win anything to win so uh you
never know those little things those
small little details might put us over
the hump or help us get a dub so I'm
always doing 100 man you know the last
Prime Time game we had versus the
Bengals it was tough it was tough
between you and Josh and you know on
Monday
it was it was love between you and Josh
you know over the off season there's a
lot of rumors a lot of trade rumors a
lot of chatter
um you know this was a different picture
than what we saw you know from the last
time that we played last season
um do you feel like there's any you know
misconceptions or or anything that
happened between you and Josh over at
obviously yeah because I mean you go in
after 20 game
off a 20 Game season your last image of
me and Josh was uh the last after the
fourth down I'm saying they say a
picture is worth a thousand words so you
can garnish whatever you want from that
image and create a narrative behind it
and it'll fit I'm saying obviously
there's no football being played there's
just a lot of commentary and he says he
or she say so for me I feel like uh the
comments conception was was that I
wanted to leave but it was like
um I never said that you know I'm saying
I never came out my mouth and said I
never had a conversation with anybody
that said it was just a tweet and it was
just like just a tweet that said come
and rescue me yeah yeah like I'm like
damn like I thought I thought we all
listen to Drake at one point you know
I'm saying of course like I like to you
know sometimes I do poke the bear I hope
to Bear people all the time but in the
same majority of the time is it's
Twitter or Instagram and I say listen
their social media you know I'm saying
you use it how you want but we're all
grown ass people I'm saying like and as
an adult I feel like I'm on this on
whatever I say you know I'm saying but I
feel like at one point some people dive
too deep into things or take it however
they want to take it so for me I also
say I'm not responsible for how people
react to things I'm not responsible for
it um how somebody feels I'm more so
responsible on how I carry and I'm just
happy to have my quarterback yeah man um
you know like I said on the sideline
it's always easier it's easier to play
quarterback on the sideline when you're
watching
um never been on the sideline like I
have you know these last couple of games
but actually watching the game and
watching the offense and defense equally
like you know a lot of wide receivers
say I'm always open like I feel like I
feel like
I was watching
on every single play that she was out
there it was a point in time within that
play that she was open like so it was it
is it is true like when Dick say I'm
always open like he was actually always
open
um you know we talked about on the
sideline too I was like man and I was I
was really out there watching there's a
point in time on every single play that
you was open you know what I'm saying
probably it's tough it's tough and then
again it's tough to play quarterback
especially when you got a rush like the
the Jets had with Huff number 47 coming
and Quentin Williams like right when he
got the ball like he had the scramble
and you know things changed like
quarterbacks is the hardest position in
all the sports so you know of course you
could just say hey just watch Diggs the
whole play and he gonna be open at some
point but yeah it just don't it just
don't work sound good it sound good but
hey I can't I'll voucher and it's a
point in time
you know we both team captains
um you know what is that what is that
what does that mean to you you know
after at the off season and you know
coming back to the team now what does
that mean to be a cabinet for you I had
I had talked a little bit about it in
like on the media they had asked me that
question I was like at this point in my
career probably feels it feels a lot
better than it did the first time the
first time you know like you want to be
a captain you want to you know I'm
trying to do everything right but now
with everything that transpire like even
with the off season all the chatter and
like that like going into the
season I felt like I'm gonna put my
focus on back on everything that I it
was on before like when football was
going on like I'm locked in a football
you saw like still it was a lot of
chatter going into uh going into even
when I was in Camp and I was like this
damn like you would feel like a lot of
stuff was like I nipped it in the bud or
we kind of like figured that out but I
feel like at one point
um the comments or anything it was kind
of just to throw a wrench in there or
like to throw people off or like you
know I'm saying kind of throw up the
stuff that we was building but for me
that was my main focus to keep the main
thing the main thing and I'm saying and
then I feel like a lot of other people
some people that was just doing like the
sand stuff for clicks trying to be
involved and I get it I'm saying but I
hope the best for whatever platform they
do have you see I'm saying but I try not
to get into it especially considering
the fact that I'm earning the respect to
my teammates I want to respect to my
coaches they know who I am they know how
I am they know how serious I'll take the
game so when I was voted to Captain
again that's why I said it meant that
much more that people acknowledge that
no I'm like he's serious about his
business I don't know all the chatter
and all he said she said he's serious
about it
every day every day for me for me being
voter team captain is is so dope to be
around those guys each and every day
when you have good days when you have
bad days you know you spend more time at
the facility around those guys than you
do with your own family yeah so to be
voted team captain by those guys that
really know me that's really around me
it means it means a lot to me man and
you know you know obviously we have
different leadership styles I feel like
my leadership style is more
um the psychology part of it like I like
to really like know guys and then like
you know really come from a place of
love and then like influence them to
like be better than what they know that
they can be and everybody has different
leadership styles and I uh eight
captains you know it's a purpose for
each and every one but I'll ask you
what's what's your leadership style
uh it depends on the guy like that's one
thing I would say I kind of learned from
like my little brothers like I got two
little brothers or three little brothers
but two of them that was really into
football
you could love them up differently like
one of them could take tough love one of
them can take like you know me yelling
at him or me being like super hard on
the other one you kind of gotta have a
conversation with like tell me what
you're thinking like that's how I can
help you like I just feel like also that
kind of goes into parenting as well like
all your kids gonna be different like
everybody not gonna be the same so for
me and kind of the same thing that goes
into the leadership stuff just uh all
your teammates gonna be different I'm
saying you're coming from a place of
love just like you said and it's kind of
like you really gotta learn them a
little bit you got to get to know him
you know I'm saying and then like even
saying you can kind of go for that but
my main thing is leading by example like
at the very minimum if I don't say
anything if you see how I work and see
how I approach the game each and every
day you'll want to at least respect me
enough to be like I gotta work at the
very minimum
um so you know we're not gonna overreact
on our loss it's only week one but you
wouldn't watch Trayvon play yeah
um the night before our game
um you know how dope was that is it is
it too early to overreact about the cat
how good the Cowboys are 40 to Zero
versus the Giants I agree of a Cowboys
fan yeah me too we all grew up like this
is my team
um I try not to put the carriage before
the horse but I'm always having high
hopes for the Cowboys uh deep down
inside like as you can see me my other
little brother like we'd be pulling for
Trey uh harder than we put anybody
because you were we were a fan of the
team before he got there and then you
got a family member on there I don't
know it just takes it it takes it
another step so for me I have a lot of
appreciate it and then when I get to see
my brother I don't know it's like I wish
everybody could enjoy or experience
having a family member you know I'm
saying not only did you reach a
profession but better yet your younger
sibling did you know I'm saying and he
had signed a contract as well that was
something that we were super ecstatic
for uh proud of him but then going into
that season I'm like all right now I'm
like show me what you got everything you
worth some money now and I just I just
poke a little fun at him so it's
definitely something uh I would just
love I love doing he actually came to
the game came to argument I saw him he
came to his game and he he came to our
game it was dope man you recently told
uh Pat McAfee that you would be a top
five Corner in the league yeah women
makes you say that because I watched my
little brother do it and I was like if
my brother play receiver his whole his
whole life yeah I'm saying he went to
Alabama he played Corner the last two
years then came in the league and showed
me that it's all about having ball skits
obviously having feet and being able to
move but being an athlete if you're a
true athlete you're saying you could
have played any I could have played
Safety I could have played any of those
positions I feel like if you can run
break and you got some Competitive Edge
I feel like I feel like I got a chance
and I feel like I got a knack for the
ball I talked to my little brother had
like a couple pictures first game first
year and I was like if you could if you
just caught a half of the ones you
dropped you would have had a better year
you end up grabbing 12 picks and I was
like oh yeah it's easy I probably I need
I need to get involved if you if you're
a top five Corner who would be the other
four
um that's a great question I say my
brother I'm saying probably be a little
higher than me
um Darius Slay
past her team examine Howard
I'm trying to figure out if I forgetting
any names
hate forgetting guys because uh jair
Alexander also a numbers and a healthy
Marshawn Lattimore for sure for sure
um you said you could do both
oh Mr kid in college that's actually
doing both high level and killing it on
both sides of the ball Travis Hunter
um you call him a generational Talent
you know what makes him special it's uh
not only is he condition anything I saw
him after the game he had like 120 snaps
in the locker room dancing I'm saying
and me I probably would have been in the
ice tub somewhere he's just one of those
generational Thompson something we
haven't seen very often
um fluid he actually gives you he
actually supports my uh cause or my case
when I say I got to play both sides of
the ball he's a hell of a receiver and
he goes on the other side and shows you
what he can do at DB playing space well
making plays on the ball him saying he
ain't really bad and everything now he's
trying to catch it yeah so I mean I feel
like that's part of the battle
especially at DB if you can make plays
on the ball
um you're not halfway bad but he's he's
definitely somebody special and
something we need to keep our close eyes
on not only this year but moving forward
so man Dion said that Travis is him but
I thought I thought it was him
I'm gonna see you I'm gonna give it to
him right now before anybody asks her in
there I'm gonna say that's him for sure
I feel like you know I feel like I have
to play I feel like I can play both
sides of the ball too I feel like a plan
though
completely defensive end I ain't seen
you really catch though I could catch I
started out catching I started out on
the offensive side of the ball yeah but
that was like 30 years I don't know but
you know the hands down the hands yeah
the hands don't go nowhere especially
you know you know she like seeing these
guys block and yeah you know they be
trying to block me this is how you gotta
this is how you gotta block them you
know what I'm saying like you got to
come off so you think you could block
you I think yeah I could mix it up I
think I can mix it up I can mix it up on
it and then the thing is you have the
advantage on the offensive side of the
ball too because I know to play I know
the snap count so on defense I don't and
I still I'm still able to jump the snap
you know how hard it is I know I know I
know but I would mix I just feel like I
can mix it up I can mix it up You've Won
majority of battles so what do you think
you block yourself I'll mix it up on
them and then honestly like I would do
like the little things that I know like
piss me off like what like grabbing
fingers
I'm trying to twist them and then
walking off blocking to the wheels
I would do all the little stuff that I
know like that that pissed me off but
you know Travis he plays both sides and
I always like to put my my GM hat on and
if I when if I was drafted in Travis
Hunter
I would actually have them play both
sides of the ball like I would I
wouldn't take that away from him like I
would let him you know obviously my job
would obviously be on the line once I
did that but I just believe it I believe
and you know he's done it all the way up
until that point so I was given the
opportunity to do it in the league too
whatever he wanted to do whatever he
felt comfortable with I would let him
play offense I would let him play
defense Champ Bailey actually did it
played defense and he came in here wide
receiver snaps too so I would limit him
on some on some parts of it but I would
let him figure out you know which one is
he wanted to do and then as he got older
then he could then he could pick us up
you know what's crazy uh me paying
attention to the game you know you watch
enough football to notice
um guys like that like if you let them
play both sides of the ball you it's
going to be like where are you going to
draft him I'm saying if you're in corner
knee every team's in need of a corner is
a team in need of a receiver hopefully
it's a team in need of both yeah I'm
saying that he can actually mix it up on
both sides but I think he's a guy that
could be a full-time corner and get
receiver reps or be the first full-time
receiver that get Corner rest or I'm
saying like I saw what I think if I
needed a receiver I would take him if
even if we had cornerbacks I would still
take him and give him opportunity on the
other side like even if we didn't need
corners on the other side I would still
give him the opportunity yeah the
challenge would come
when he does play both sides and he
plays at a high level at both yeah when
it's time to pay this guy like no no no
no I'm telling you he's gonna be
wondering what is off the board when
it's time to pay this guy probably the
second player off the board if it's not
two quarterbacks say if he comes in the
league and he does what he does in at
the college level he's great at corner
he's a top five receiver and he's a top
five Corner four years later five first
the first three to four hundred million
dollar players
that would be that would be the
challenge like when it's time to paint
in My Pan I'm like top five corners get
top five top five corners get paid crazy
and top five receivers even if you're
not a top five Corner let's say your top
ten ten team get paid crazy still
getting he would I mean he'll probably
demand like double that double that that
I wanted the receiver because I played
both yeah it's crazy man um let's play a
game man all right here we go let's go
um I'm gonna give you a fellow wide
receiver and you'll tell me how you
would cover them all right
put my corner hat on and we're going
against Gabe Davis how was you going
uh off coverage I'm playing uh
inside out
um and I'm being as physical as I can at
the top because he's big yeah he he is
physical too people don't even
understand how physical Gabe is and he's
a big body Big Country body he's he's uh
lifter of the Year see every year that
he's been with the Buffalo Bills yeah
um what about Jamar Chase
I don't know like Jamar you see like
thicker guy Jamar is really built like a
little mini like running back strong and
saying you got them LSU Roots so I don't
know man I'm kind of I just got to play
Bump the whole time I'm bumping around
the whole time you say that's your best
chance and even then you probably don't
got that good of a chance Justin
Jefferson another another LSU girl
bump and running I might need some help
action
up over the top and be as aggressive as
I can at the point of contact uh what
about Tariq listen we know what we said
we need some help yeah
I mean I actually need at this time like
I'm saying like stay all the way over
the top and we still might need an extra
guy I mean but you you might not need
you said you could beat him in a 100
yard dash yeah we were saying I was
saying that but that wasn't that wasn't
an accurate statement you must not
haven't seen him the other day running
around oh yeah the other day man it was
crazy man he had 11 reception 200 he had
11 receptions 215 yards two touchdowns
in the game on Sunday to pop it off
right running real real fast it was
crazy man it looks impressive what about
Gary Wilson
yeah he's young so I mean I would
actually try to just mix it up with him
a little bit like play outside play
inside I switch up my leverage a lot you
know I'm saying try to give them
something different each time just
because he Shifty like real shifting I'm
saying if you're not on your p's and q's
he might drop you off so we talked about
me blocking myself yeah let's talk about
stuff guarding stiff how would you guard
yourself you can't yeah you can send
help you can bump you know I'm saying I
feel like I I see so many different DBS
and so many people have played sat in
front of me that my game is a game of
its own like I try to be consistently
inconsistent I try to make plays on the
ball I'm strong at the point of contact
and I um I'm gonna give you something
different every time and I'm playing
with a little bit of I'm playing with a
little bit of like if I call University
that'd be crazy that'd be crazy to see
you somebody can't somebody can't win
it's probably not okay let's let's
reverse the rose and let's say Trayvon
played receiver yeah he wouldn't catch a
bottom how would you go he said you're
gonna tell you the same thing I wouldn't
catch a ball he wouldn't catch the ball
on me and I feel like ironically enough
at the end of the year it's going to be
a cold day of Buffalo but gonna be
warm for me I'm gonna be like I told him
about how your hamstrings ready because
I'm gonna be running so yeah so y'all
had a wrestling match yeah yeah had a
wrestling match he beat you on the
wrestling match yeah but that
started I'm not wrestling like come on
now this ain't WWE
uh what was it like what was it like
playing against him in the Pro Bowl it
was cool I feel like I don't know like
the things that I'm experiencing in life
right now people with very few people
ever will get to experience or I'm
saying even have feelings of like this
like to be at the highest level and him
saying like come on now like who who is
in the Pro Bowl throwing picks to their
little brother like on purpose I was
trying to give him but you know I'm
saying just the experience of it and
things like that I feel like my life is
extremely best like blessed beyond
measure at this point because I'm
experiencing stuff that people don't
necessarily get to experience and it's
coming so from a place of love like when
I see him having success I'm just like
this damn man look think about it that's
my little brother that's kind of cool
yeah that's dope man is uh is he your
favorite person your favorite person to
train with uh yeah because I like my
little brother is so damn talented like
I feel like I try to motivate him or try
to push him in each and every way and I
always uh I always get on his get on his
ass all the time so yeah
he recently got the bag yeah who picks
up the tab now him I don't picked it up
for a long time yeah come on I've been
stomach in the lobe of pause for a long
time but he said my man got to take care
of me for me or not you know I'm like
the old man so at least for a couple of
years and he had to team up on some
stuff all right there's been a lot of
talk about contracts in the in the news
recently um Joe Barrow just went crazy
um what is your what is your take on Joe
Barrow becoming the highest paid player
in NFL history I mean that quarterback
position is definitely one of a kind
like especially if you had success uh
they deserve all the money that they get
you know I'm saying good because if it's
all good it's always falls on them if
it's all bad it always falls I don't
care what happens in each game so for me
uh it's a lot of it's a lot of pressure
on the QB and I'm saying and it's a hard
job to have children to see him have him
saying a record-breaking contract uh it
was congrats to him like you saw him in
that year they went to the Super I feel
like he was one of the highest sacked
quarterbacks in the league I'm saying to
be having that production and still be
sticking in there to be tough uh not
just mentally but physically because he
was taking some shots so for me I mean I
always say the kid deserved the money
deserves the money um especially if they
earn it uh they they hell of a talent so
it's gonna be interesting to see what's
next especially that range of
quarterbacks making 50 I'm sorry it's
usually the next thing that happens is
the receiver with a left higher I'm all
for like the quarterback getting you
should want like guys to get as much
money as possible especially the
quarterback because like you said then
the defensive end gets paid more then
the left tackle gets paid more then the
wide receiver gets paid more it just it
just goes up and up and up and the the
quarterback is the Catalyst for that
um what we did see miles Garrett one of
the highest paid defensive ends in Joe
Barrel go at it and it it wasn't nice we
had miles Garrett doing the basketball
crossover
and his first step for a big fella is
something like a basketball hey 290
Pounds yes
he's 299 it's unfair
uh Daniel Jones
third highest conversation over the next
two years you know he went crazy as well
then Nick Bosa like I said once the
quarterback goes up once the quarterback
goes up everybody else goes up and Nick
Bosa was right there with him
um and this means for Michael Parsons
that he will he will get paid 40 million
dollars a year it's looking like a 40
piece
he get paid 40 million dollars a year I
said that last year though that's it
that's that's like that's exceptional
man look at that number that's that's a
big number you walk away with a lot a
lot of money I feel like you know if you
if you was five years younger you'll be
right here popping up right now with the
200.
as long as possible I'll never look back
I don't know I get back man I just keep
going man I'm trying to get as much as I
can get man let's take a look uh let's
take a look ahead to week two you know
playing the Raiders you know the Raiders
are the only 1-0 team in the AFC West
what are the keys to bounce back in week
two first uh just stay in the course
um they got a good backhand their DC
does a is out with mixing it up has a
rolodexo coverage that he likes to play
but I feel like just taking what they
give us because keeping our foot on
their gas stand and attack them all I'm
saying let's not even get in the space
of ever comfortable yeah I want every
every play every second to feel like
we're applying pressure and
um to let that roll off our
back like you know I'm saying like we
can't do nothing about it especially
that happens in the past I feel
like going forward uh that's going
that's going to keep driving us and
that'll motivate us to do everything
that we want to do because I remember a
couple years ago we took a l
um the season open and we came in and
rung off like four or five straight I'm
saying it's possible you know what I'm
saying but I think the key still right
now is it's hone in on the details for
this week take what they give us I'm
saying be that be that offense that
everybody knows that we could be 100 man
and um you know like Josh had a tough
game and I never like I never like try
to give advice on how to do your job I
just like to be present I just like to
be present like I like to be present and
support my God like I don't never like
talk about like what happened in the
game I just wanted to know like you know
I'm I'm there like regardless like for
you like how do you go about like you
know boosting Josh's confidence and
helping him out with tough situations
like one in the game I just try to
catch as many passes for him so like
he's getting into that registry
[Laughter]
that's my God like it my my biggest
thing is that positive reinforcement
like when things are getting when we are
in a high pressure heightened you know
anxiety whatever it is football is that
I'm saying so if you can bring a guy
down a couple of notches in those
moments him saying you just never know
how much further you can go as a team so
for me I just try to give them like hey
we got this like don't even worry about
him saying let's let's play hard let's
play smart like when they see like like
I have seen
um
um something like Michael Irvin has said
he don't like when I point at my head
like or something like that that you
know and I was like I'm like what are
you talking about you know I'm saying
like people people garnish like things
from a game and have their own opinion
about XYZ like what are you talking
about I feel like I say that's to the
quarterback I say this to the running
back I say this to the receivers to the
o-line I always say play hard and play
smart and when you see me point in my
head I say let's play smart you say I'm
signing for the Olan that's like don't
let's not be holding for the receivers I
stay on size that's um I'm saying get
your depth just like little stuff like
that so for me like I just feel like
like when I even got that information I
heard that I was like what are you
talking about I never want to be that
guy yeah like I get it I'm done when I'm
done playing football it's 40 years ago
when you was running routes
like I respect the ogs but I feel like
damn like you know some some stuff is
worth conversation and other stuff it's
like
all right all right all right all right
we're going against Jimmy G
um you know I played against Jimmy G
when I was in the AFC West NFC West for
a short period of time and he's a great
quarterback yeah um he's proven it time
and time again until the team to the
Super Bowl
um I feel like we just got to apply
pressure that's that's for any
quarterback once you can get in their
face
um once you can like get a couple of
sacks that's right you know once you
once you attack the head then you know
the body the body will crumble and the
quarterbacks are the head you know you
got Marcus Peters on the other side you
know he uh this is his first time you
know coming back from knee injuries 100
and when you're excited to line him
against Marcus Peterson yeah he's always
always been a um always been one of the
better DBS in the league especially uh
getting his hands on the ball uh hell of
a talent I feel like he's he's always he
talks too like he talks to him he played
him for some years though it's like me
and him never really got into that kind
of thing though like we know like you
know me I like to talk trash a little
bit or talk with like like other
players but it's never really liked that
in the game you know I'm saying like
it's only it only get on that when
somebody else on that but for the most
part I just like the hoop and we that's
the talking right there like if you
beat me I'm saying because that's the
only thing that matter right yeah yeah
here today and gone tomorrow before
um you know we we let you go and we get
into these fan questions we have to
shout out
a Bills fan who baptized his baby okay
with the bat with the black labatt's
beer and a folding table all right don't
you actually put the beard put the beer
across his head like this had a little
cross
and then he put it across his chest yo
that is crazy said in the name of Stefan
Diggs Von Miller Jordan poyer yes
Michael High by the power vested in me
no listen to this now about a power
vested in me
[Music]
uh shout out my God man Bill's Mafia so
crazy man shut up big shout out
um you know uh it's super dope man and
before I let you go man we got a couple
uh fan questions as well
says if you had to pick a Drake lyric
for how you feeling this season how
would it be damn I wish you would give
me some preparation you got so many oh
exactly
um
man
oh no I'm gonna come back to that one
okay number two
who is the Stefan Diggs of the NBA
Jimmy Butler
Jimmy Butler I might be I mean Jimmy
Butler just knows how to get a bucket
you know what I'm saying he gets his job
done on all fronts he's been doing it
you're saying can't do it he's been
doing it in our respect he a dog and
then Dave people you might say whatever
they want to say I don't know what they
say about what they they for sure gonna
say he a dog and this one for me says yo
Von when is the next haircut coming it's
the same one it's the same I put another
triangle on this side though but it's
the same it's just the same one I've
been working
it's the same woman
[Music]
um
you know uh man I appreciate you man for
coming on the show man like always man
if you ever need me for anything man you
know I got you man
um this is a great way to to start off
Devon cast season two there we go there
we go you guys keep uh tuning in to see
who we're gonna get on next and it's
gonna be dope man as y'all can tell we
started out with Stefan Diggs man so we
got to keep going oh no we can top that
but we just got to keep going man y'all
tune in next time for for our next guest
man and I appreciate y'all
foreign
[Music]